welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of dune
part one of director denny villeneuve's
adaptation of frank herbert's novel a
stunning film with deeper layers of
meaning and such astute attention to
detail that you leave this movie with a
spice contact high i loved dune and i am
gonna break it down scene by scene to
explain some details that you might have
missed some broader context from the
novel and the filmmaking elements worthy
of appreciation the film opens cold even
before the studio title card so when
you're watching this in the theater
you're like is the movie starting with
this quote
[Music]
now this quote is actually not from
herbert's novel but a line added by the
move to frame part one of this story as
one about the power of dreams for paul
tradies they're messages from the deep
within his subconscious hinting at his
destined path as a chosen one but also
physically from the deep from the shy
hallowed sandworms of arrakis with whom
paul attains a spiritual connection by
the movie's end suggesting these dreams
may be their siren call to beck and paul
deeper into the deserts of dune but as
we learn in the final act the prophetic
accuracy of these dreams is really
called into question empowering paul
with the choice to forge his own destiny
now this deep voice is a man speaking
sardocar the language of the elite
commandos of the emperor the sardikar's
army's chance used throat singing known
for a mongolian as well as tibetan and
northern european traditions we meet
them a bit later but then guiding us
through the prologue is the voice of
chunny the freeman woman of paul's
dreams as she describes arrakis rolling
over the sands
you can see spice in the air
composer han zimmer's percussion beats
steadily evoking the thumper device
which redirects the sand worms with the
sound of a beating heart and we learned
about spice aka melange this is the
precious natural resource of this whole
universe it's found only on the planet
arrakis aka dune in frank herbert's
novel it was really an analog for middle
eastern oil here villeneuve shows it as
glitter dust a kind of magic like
imagine a place where this precious gold
just blows around on the ground now the
film only somewhat goes into it but
spice is really a powerful drug that
enables interstellar travel and commerce
but not as fuel this is a product that's
consumed by guild navigators who are
genetically engineered beings who use
melange to enhance their minds to
rapidly compute complex navigation
equations and this society needs this
because of a past butlerian jihad
against thinking machines aka computers
or ai but what i love about this movie
is that it doesn't bog things down too
much on this literary backstory and just
kind of sticks to the exposition that
paula tradies needs on his journey and
yes by the way the whole desert planet
setting spice as a drug mystical psychic
powers and an emperor were all world
details that george lucas took for his
star wars universe after reading
herbert's 1965 novel dune game first
again it's like poetry so if they rhyme
johnny details their oppression by the
harkonnens and then the harkins ordered
departure why did the emperor choose
this path
and who will our next oppressors be
contextualizing this whole prologue is
really chinese dream message to paula
tradies and leaving us with the question
of the cycle of oppression see herbert's
texts go further into how religious
radicalism can begin as a noble cause
but eventually becomes its own evil when
the oppressed become the next oppressors
and yes villeneuve opens with part one
in the title to signal to viewers that
like the fellowship of the ring this is
really part one of a longer narrative
and to not expect definitive finality by
the end of the movie it lists the year
as 10 0191 but to be clear that is 10191
ag after guild referring to the point
that the spacing guild was formed and
monopolized space travel and banking and
that year was believed to be in our
calendar around 11 000 a.d so these
events are set close to 22 000 a.d in
our time paul eats breakfast with his
mother lady jessica a concubine of the
duke lado atreides and she is a nun with
the benny jesterate order a group of
sorceress nuns who have spent centuries
running the secret breeding program to
bring about their prophesied messiah
queen
the new adds a new scene that's not the
novel to show their use of the
telepathic voice
[Music]
i love the editing here as paul focuses
on his mother the light shifts on the
portrait this is actually paul's
grandfather lado's father paulus known
for bullfighting thus his matador red
cloak and that table statue house
atreides is one of the noble families
who can actually trace their lineage
back to earth and the people of greece
and in greek myth fighting the cretan
bull was one of the laborers of heracles
and the minotaur was of course part bull
meanwhile the rival house harkinin gets
their name from hyarkonen a finnish
surname that's derived from the word
harka translating to bull so a bit of
foreshadowing with the fate of lado at
the horns of the bull which lato does
again at his father's gravestone
depicting that bullfight and grandfather
fought bulls for sport yes
look where that got him but while he
uses the boys paul moves his lips but
the only sound we hear initially are
thumper beats and then another voice
comes in a bit delayed and it's
distorted in this creepy demonic snarl
showing how it's channeled from some
external force
and then jessica moves the glass and
then opens her eyes signaling that she
did this unconsciously i mean folks
nothing against star wars but this is a
far more visceral depiction than the way
the jedi used the force which yeah
george lucas got pretty much from the
voice in dune the emperor's herald
arrives how much would it cost them
traveling all this way for this
formality
three guild navigators a total of 1.46
million 62 salaries round trip yes this
is superior hawat the mentat of house of
treaties mentats are advisors trained to
perform rapid mental analysis to replace
computers of this world and this little
moment shows both the mentat's function
and the duke's wariness over the
emperor's excess and sending this herald
the emperor is making the duke an offer
he can't refuse paul greets duncan idaho
a pilot in swordmaster stabilizers are
too loose could see this is a little
detail forewarning the loose stabilizer
wings paul will have to deal with while
piloting his ornithopter later on in the
sandstorm and paul mentions his dream
vision of duncan's death i felt like if
i had been there
he'd be alive and yes there's this
close-up of a desert beetle which duncan
later plays with right before the
starter car arrived to kill him gurney
halek mentors paul don't stand with your
back to the door
it tells you by your footsteps gurney
halley
someone might imitate my stride
i know the difference later on paul will
repeat these words to gurney when he
rescues him from the sand worm i
recognize your footsteps
and if you think about the worms also
hear their footsteps necessitating the
thumper to imitate their stride but paul
with his mystical linkage with the sand
worms would know the difference now
during their sparring they use these
shields that glow blue when rapid
strikes hit them but glow red to show
slower strikes penetrating them now in
the books these are called holzmann
generators which prevent the use of lace
gun beams because a generator being hit
with a beam could trigger a nuclear
explosion that would kill everyone in
the vicinity so instead in this world
blades are used in close combat and
you'll notice throughout this movie they
use a combat style of swift blows but as
they come in for the kill slower strikes
moving at a speed of six to nine
centimeters per second because that's
how slow you have to move to penetrate
the shield and we meet baron vladimir
harkenin morbidly obese who uses
anti-gravity suspensers on his back to
float and stay upright now spoiler
warning for the prelude to dune prequel
series and potentially for part two of
this film but this obesity was actually
a disease cursed upon him by the
reverend mother of the benny jesuit who
manipulated the baron who's sexually
homosexual into having sex with him and
collecting his genetic material to
produce an offspring that offspring
being lady jessica as a whole part of
their breeding program to produce their
messiah and then enraged the baron raped
the reverend mother so in retribution
she cursed him now we will see if this
ends up being the backstory in the films
but it is hinted at by the reverend
mother snapping at lady jessica for
wasting their efforts on a male heir so
much potential wasted in a male we were
told to bear only daughters and hinted
at by the baron calling duke lado cousin
another wonderful kixy cousin but here
the baron runs his hand across his bald
head which has got to be an homage to
marlon brando's gesture as kurtz in
apocalypse now whose infamous
exterminate them all order the baron
actually alludes to later kill them all
now the interstellar travel is depicted
in this movie with these massive tubular
structures in orbit through which on the
other side you can see another planet
making this a kind of wormhole portal
through space and then as paul walks up
to the gamja bar test he tugs at his
neck collar on his left side his nerves
already tingling from the needle that
will soon threaten the spot jessica
speaks to paul and dr yue with sign
language this is called battle language
in the books and it's hand signals used
to prevent enemies from intercepting
messages here it's a way of telling paul
that he needs to keep his guard up the
reverend mother uses the voice on paul
and it is super effective come here
i love it from paul's perspective
there's this unfocused pulling of
darkness and again great editing because
he travels the full length of the room
in an instant before we even realize
what just happened now we never see what
is in the box leaving it to timothy
chalamet to express the pain inside as
well as again some great editing they
intercut the burning palm trees of
arrakis as in the book this pain is
described as paul's flesh feeling like
it is burning off meanwhile outside
jessica chants this prayer
[Music]
is the little
yes this is the most famous passage from
herbert's dune a phrase that echoes in
paul's mind during this sequence and
specifically the words turn the inner
eye in this context for shadows paul
facing the shaholug its mouth designed
to look like a giant eye that paul gazes
into as he faces his fear and the music
is amazing throughout this film composed
by hans zimmer and here you hear this
fierce female vocal
this is singer lori cutler who in this
case is singing a made-up language that
sounds like it is based at least
partially on hebrew now as they arrive
on arrakis i love the contrasting design
of the atreides fleet its angular blocky
ships which is also reflected in their
chunky armor compared to the fleet of
house harkenin which is more rounded in
bulbus like the baron and his nephew
robin themselves house of tradies
arrives on arrakis where the local
fremen identified paul as the son
al-gaib it's their name for messiah it
means the penitentiary i've been at work
here landing superstitions preparing the
way paul you see what they've been told
to say yeah paul is annoyed how the
benny jessrick was manipulating the
fremen religion this way but in reality
he too is seeing what he has been told
to see his dream visions are not going
to always match up with the truth now we
all know we should be saving money and
investing it beyond diamond handing my
animorse novel collection i don't have
much of an investing strategy that's why
we're excited to partner with this video
sponsor public.com public.com is the
investing platform we can buy thousands
of stocks etfs and cryptos for any
amount of money and share ideas within a
community of investors public helps
people become better investors there's
an interactive and educational community
in a social feed so that you can learn
and build confidence while investing on
public you can buy slices of stock etfs
or crypto instead of full shares
alongside thousands of stocks and etfs
public offers 11 crypto assets cryptos
on public include bitcoin bitcoin cash
cardano ethereum ethereum classic
litecoin stellar dash zcash doge and
shiba inu what i love about public is
that public puts investors first and
doesn't sell your trades to market
makers or other investment apps they
route the trades directly to the
exchanges there are zero commission fees
on standard trades and zero account
minimums to get started it's also backed
by big names like tony hawk will smith
and some of the original investors in
venmo so go to public.com new rockstars
and receive up to 70
and a slice of stock when you open the
count with public and make a deposit the
ornithopters have this amazing dragonfly
design but still maintains the
militaristic hum of real-life apache
helicopters and they arrive at the city
of arakeen and the immensity of the
palace is hinted at with these big piles
of sand that have collected on all the
sloped surfaces gurney observes the
multiple moons of arrakis the larger one
crown referred to as the hand of god for
the canyon that looks like a hand the
production designers actually used as a
reference point a real-life canyon
pattern on the surface of mars that's
called the valles marineris then a
hunter seeker burrows into paul's
bedroom operated by an assassin hidden
in the walls of the palace still which
is terrifying paul uses a projected
educational video to hide in the brush
showing how in a way kind of like the
rhythmic walking in the desert to avoid
the sand worms paul is beginning to
adapt to araka's survival instincts and
he notices this kangaroo mouse and the
shrubbery this is actually called the
muadib and we see one of these later on
in the movie in close up and how it
collects moisture and its adorable
little ears showing how it's perfectly
adapted to this desert climate now muay
deeb is hugely significant to paul's
journey it's also the name that the
fremen give that larger moon with the
hand of god and the name that paul goes
on to take when he's among the fremen so
yeah this connection with the mouse is
hugely significant as we are looking
ahead to part two meanwhile the baron
keeps this terrifying spider pet with
human hands this ain't in the book folks
but it might be to replace the even
creepier pets the baron keeps in the
book which is just young boys but i'm
wondering if this could be a freak
genetic experiment from the ben a
teleacts but there are some fan theories
out there that this could be dr ue's
wife based off of what he said later
they take her apart like a doll yeah i
don't know about that at least i hope
for her sake that's not the case freeman
leader stilgar greets them and they
exchange the dignity of spitting at each
other giving each other the gift of
moisture but this moment actually
reframes the earlier exchange between
paul and his mother give me the water as
a deeper pledge to help each other
survive in the desert when hawaii shows
them the spice silos notice how there
are far fewer of them than when we saw
in the opening prologue the fully
stocked silos when the harkonnens were
running things this could be a little
clue showing how the harkonnens took out
a lot of their equipment so that it
wouldn't get damaged when they returned
to bomb the city we made imperial
ecologist dr liet kind who equips them
with the fremen still suits that recycle
water from the body's sweat and other
moisture to keep you rehydrated and then
out in the desert the carry all
malfunctions so they have to evac the
harvester crew but a dust cloud kicked
up by the surfacing worm billows over
paul and spice puts him in this trance
yeah we hear that demon voice again
whispering to paul identifying him as
the penny gesture at messiah with the
melange in the shai hallude as that
message from the deep calling to him the
harvester gets devoured by the shah lud
first seen only by its outer mouth with
these outer teeth as these long strands
much like the balleen of a whale that
like in the case of the whale is
designed to filter out the elements that
would get sucked in i gotta say it's a
beautiful sight almost like nature
reclaiming what rightfully belongs to it
now later paul explains to his mother
that he saw a vision of his death at the
hands of chani who's using a kris knight
another example of how his visions might
not be exact prophecies they give
disputing interpretations of the future
he also foresees jessica's pregnancy and
her giving birth to his sister alia who
will play a major role in part two of
this story now on salusa secundas the
sardocar prepare for deployment anointed
with blood and you can see that they get
this by draining it from rows of other
men that are pinned upside down in the
books starter card do have various
secret rituals but here it seems like a
spartan ritual to drain the life force
from the weaker candidates who don't
make the cut to empower the warriors who
do and so the assault on arcane begins
and thanks to the betrayal of the tragic
dr ua the shields get lowered and the
city of arakane gets bombed as gurney
leads me into one of the ships it goes
boom boom and we see some wonderful
scale in this film with gurney's men in
the lower left corner of frame as you
see a piece of fuselage blowing it past
them now we do not see gurney's fate in
this movie this guy's gonna return in
part two don't worry thanos ain't going
nowhere duncan fights his way through
the palace and at one point he uses
anti-gravity suspensers just like the
ones in baron's back to levitate and
knee that starter car and then on the
thopter jessica spots a frame kit
beneath paul's seat with that diamond
marking and then later in the tent they
find a note with the same diamond this
is a symbol on dr ue's forehead and this
comes from the souk inner school where
these tattoos signal that these doctors
cannot fully betray their patience and
violate their oath to do no harm which
is probably how dr ua was able to
justify this betrayal by giving the duke
the poisoned tooth by giving jessica and
paul this gear to help them the baron
taunts the duke your son is dead your
concubine is dead tonight the house of a
trade is full oscar isaac has to play
paralyzed but he sheds a single tear to
convey all of his grief he crushes the
poison tooth that dr ue gave him and the
editing delays this reveal of the final
gift from dr ua to paul until after the
death and we learned that it is his
father's atreides ring so paul and
jessica find out right as we do now
spice wafts into the tent and paul
experiences another vision a future holy
war led by himself and other freeman
warriors in earth tone armor cutting
through the starter car as behind him a
shy hellude burst out of the sand but
then this vision extends further into
the future showing friend conquering his
home planet of kaladan as he and shawnee
blue-eyed fremen gazing down upon this
see a holy war spreading across the
universe like unquenchable fire a
warrior religion that weighs me it's
banner in my father's name
fanatical legions worshiping at the
shrine of my father's skull now this
future does get explored further in
herbert's text the way religious
fanaticism becomes its own form of
oppression but notice how in this vision
jameis joins them so again this could be
a malleable future we're looking at
they're recovered by duncan and dr kinds
who take them to a framing outpost at an
old ecological station designed to
terraform arakis to pull the water up
out of the sand but this whole project
was abandoned since spice was discovered
and paul suggests making a play for the
emperor's throne by offering to marry
his daughter a plot point that we will
see in part two where the emperor will
finally be revealed but the starter car
catch up with them and duncan has to
fight so that they can escape dr kinds
uses a thumper to draw in the shahlud
and she draws out these hooks for her to
ride this thing i love how the worm
kicks up the dunes like a crashing
tsunami toward her making her a sort of
surfer waiting for the right wave to
come in but unfortunately she is stabbed
by a starter car spurting water from the
still suit the way blood would but here
water is essentially their blood and she
pounds the sand to beckon the shahlu to
deliver them all then in the sandstorm
paul experiences a vision of jammus as a
mentor to him we must move with the flow
of the process
we must join it
we must flow with it and this is all
part of some future lesson that'll learn
from jameis on how to ride the shyhalud
that he applies to his current crisis
just go with the flow and this is
fascinating because this person never
becomes his mentor well he is kind of a
mentor in a way but they're never
actually friends in reality this is what
lady jessica meant by paul becoming the
quisats hararak by uniting all times
paul uses one possible future to help
him survive the present and so they
crash land the thopter chained into
still suits and then initially walked
through a canyon that paul recognizes
from his dream of duncan among the
fremen another vision shows him in
shawnee finding a little cute muay deeb
don't be frightened
he find that my little desert mouse can
survive you'll need to face your fears a
friend will help you follow the friend
but this time the voice is purely that
of the external mystic speaker meaning
that paul is closer and closer to
grasping his dream except that helpful
friend is not going to be janus but
shawnee which is why her voice takes
over that voice of the speaker a
sandworm chases them down and gives us
our first real close-up look at the full
anatomy of the shyhalud it looks awesome
and then paul looks deep into it past
its outer mouths to its two inner mouths
which click at him almost in an
endearing way as if it recognizes him
respects him stilgar's group finds them
jessica manages to disarm stillgar
leading to james having to evoke the
amtol challenge twitch paul steps up as
jessica's champion but before the duel
paul once more hears the voices
to rise don't be frightened
don't resist
when you take a life
you take your own now in this vision he
sees james killing him him losing the
duel but this is only because this
vision is showing the death of his child
identity the atreides heir that his
father wanted him to be but instead
replaced by the quizadz hararak that his
mother raised him to be johnny thinking
he'll lose arms him with the kris knight
that he has been seen in his visions
empowering him with a tooth of the
shyhalud and making him realize that
this is the guide he has been destined
to follow and the mentor from his
prophecies james guiding him to this
point is really a barrier to the next
step that he has to take in his maturity
into a man a barrier that he must now
destroy and the fight goes down pretty
quickly paul abiding by the combat rules
he learned on kaladan under his father
and his father swordsmasters tries to
force james to yield but the amta is a
fight to the death and so his destiny as
the quiz hadarak is to take this life a
life for a life and that is what
transforms him into this fremen of being
who belongs in the desert finally the
moydeeb and he chooses his path my road
leads into the desert you can see it and
as he joins him into this march in the
desert he sees one of the foreign men
surfing the shia lude there's your power
fulfilling what his father actually
hoped to gain from this planet on
arrakis we need to cultivate desert
power and in the trail of the shyhalud
the fremen follow what was once a sure
sign of death and a reason to flee like
a shark fin in the water is now their
path to follow toward freedom and toward
life new rockstars does breakdowns of
everything you love so you can support
new rock stars by checking out our merch
options at nrockstarsmerch.com follow me
on instagram and twitter at eavos follow
new rockstars and subscribe for
breakdowns of everything you love and
thank you for joining us
[Music]
you